si vous me le permettez pour commencer
tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué très
rapidement mon réalisme et mon humilité
face aux résultats nationaux et
régionaux
deuxièmement je voudrais dire que ce
soir j'ai deux satisfactions
une première qui est très grande c'est à
partir de ce soir et enfin à partir de
ce soir dans chaque conseil
départemental de france il y aura autant
de femmes que d'hommes
j'insiste parce que je trouve que c'est
une condition n'est pas le cas sur notre
dernière mais c'est vrai que ce soit ça
s'est présenté comme ça ça changera des
des deux mains d'ailleurs je vais vous
poser une question à ce propos parce
qu'on a beaucoup murmurent et cette
semaine que ce pourrait être céline
maglica qui prennent le la présidence du
groupe de gauche au conseil
départemental est ce que c'est le cas et
puis on a vu aussi ce soir finalement
que c'est elle qui a le meilleur
résultat en côte d'or est-ce que ça va
compter alors je ne sais pas qui murmure
en tout cas pas moi je sais qu'il y à
une réunion d'organiser très très
prochainement au niveau de notre groupe
forces de progrès ou la bomba on va
discuter on va échanger et puis
effectivement il faudra qu'on s'organise
de telle sorte à ce qu'il y ait une
présidente ou un président donc chaude
est certaine c'est que je ne serai pas
président du je voulais quand même
revenir à la ville de dijon et
éventuellement mais l'agglo mais
l'agglomération justement alors je vous
pose la question peut-être pour vous
aider huit binômes sur neuf en côte d'or
c'est l'agglomération dijonnaise est en
gros la campagne ce sera que des
conseillers départementaux de droite est
ce que ça signifie que la gauche
aujourd'hui au parti socialiste ne parle
pas au monde rural on n'y arrive pas non
je pense pas pas le robinet
j'arrive toujours 9 mai enfin la
majorité j'allais prendre l'exemple de
paul robinat qui est conseillée mais moi
je vous prends l'exemple de saint
georges de montbard voilà t on fera en
sorte de continuer de telle sorte à ce
que le conseil général départemental
puis se sevrer autant pour l'urbain que
le rural
mais je voulais revenir si vous me
permettez sur la ville de dijon en tant
que maire de dijon pour dire qu'une fois
de plus et je tiens d'ailleurs à
profiter de l'occasion pour remercier
les électeurs et les électrices
dijonnaise une fois de plus dijon a bien
résisté par rapport à ce qu'il s'est
passé
dijon bien résisté par rapport à la
participation au scrutin
dijon a bien participé aussi par rapport
au front national
la preuve sur deux cantons 1 dijon nous
avons dû faire face à une triangulaire
et non ces deux triangulaires
le candidat de gauche l'a emporté et
largement emporté
je voulais aussi indiqué que sur la
ville de dijon qui comporte six cantons
la gauche ce soir en remportant 4 si on
va au delà au niveau de l'agglomération
dijonnaise qui comporte elle aussi six
cantons la gauche a remporté quatre si
on fait les totaux les chiffres sont
têtus
ça nous donne tout de même tout de même
huit cantons sur 12 voilà la meilleure
preuve je trouve de la résistance qui a
pu exister et au niveau de la ville de
dijon et au niveau de l'agglomération
dijonnaise